وفي تطور اخر قال وزير خارجيه ايرلندا ان
دولتين في الاتحاد الاوروبي تعطل اتفاقا
على فرض عقوبات على مستوطنين متطرفين في
الضفه لمتابعه هذا التطور والمقترح
الاسرائيلي بتوطين الفلسطينيين في هذه
الجزيره الصناعيه بدلا من غزه واهم ما
شهدته اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه اوروبا
بمشاركه وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه في
العاصمه البلجيكيه معنا من بروكسل مراسل
الجزيره عبد الله الشامي عبد الله ما وقع
هذه الفكره الاسرائيليه كيف
استقبلت هذه نعم هذه الفكره هي في الاساس
تضرب في صميم عكس ما يردده الاوروبيون
يعني كل الافكار التي تطرح حتى بما فيها
التي تتحدث عن اليوم التالي للحرب في غزه
كلها كانت ترفض رفضا قاطعا اما الافكار
التي طرحت من رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه او
حتى من المسؤولين الاوروبيين فكره تهجير
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي هذا الطرح اليوم
اصاب الكثيرين بالدهشه كونه يتنافى مع
الخطه الاوروبيه او التصور الاوروبي لهذا
اليوم الذي يطلقون عليه اليوم التالي
للحرب في ذات الوقت ايضا مساله وجود
ممانعات من دول اوروبيه يمكن ربما ان ان
نخمن من هي الدول التي تمانع فرض عقوبات
المستوطنين بنظره بسيطه الى القرار الاخير
للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده الذي كان
يدعو لوقف اطلاق النار هتان الدولتان بشكل
كبير يحتمل ان يكون المتجر و شيك التان
رفضتا وقف اطلاق النار ولهما مواقف سابقه
في رفض ايه مساس باسرائيل باي شكل من
الاشكال وبالتالي على اغلب الظن هذان
التتان هما التان تعطل يمكن ايضا ان نرجع
الى الامس الى الاخبار التي وردت حول
النقاط المتعلقه ب يعني مقترحات من
الاتحاد الاوروبي لاعضائه لوضع تصورات
لعواقب على اسرائيل هذه هي المقترحات
عندما طرحت من قبل مفو السياسات الخارجيه
على سفراء الول الاعضاء ذكر انها غير
ملزمه وبالتالي الاتحاد الاوروبي يمكن ان
نقول انه فعلا يدور في دائره مفرغه حيث
يريد ان يكون له اثر اكبر كما قال مفوض
السياسه الخارجيه اليوم يريد ان يحل
الازمه بشكل جذري في المنطقه وينشئ دولتين
جنبا الى جنب تعيشان بسلام حسب التصريح
الصادر من بوريل لكنه في نفس الوقت لا
يستطيع الزام اعضائه باي من التصورات حتى
في ابسط اشكالها وهو مساله فرض العقوبات
نعلم ان طرح العقوبات على المستوطنين
المتطر كما يسميهم في الضفه الغربيه وطرح
تبنته كل من فرنسا وهولندا وبلجيكا
وبالتالي الى ان يحل الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا
الخلاف الداخلي قد لا يبدو ممكنا له العمل
على شيء موحد وهو كما قال بورال ربما
السبب انه دعى اليوم الى جانب الوزير
الاسرائيلي وزراء فلسطين والاردن ومصر
والسعوديه لكي يكون الحل نابعا من المنطقه
كما قال بالتالي حتى الان هذا الاجتماع
الذي دخل في اكثر من ع ساعات من التواصل
بين الاتحاد والوزراء لم يصل الى ايه
نتيجه ملموسه اليوم على الاقل الى هذه
اللحظه وينتظر ان يؤجل كل شيء مره اخرى
كما يفعل الاتحاد عاده امام القرارات
المصيريه الى الاجتماع المقبل اي في التاس
عش من فبراير